The last time she was here
she told us how much she loved being a pen pal.
And she's a good one and sends mail.
So please welcome back.
The hilarious, beautiful and ever so stylish
Saturday night live cast member, Heidi Gardner.
(audience applauding)
Hi Drew
Okay. What time is that Heidi?
Dear Drew
(audience applauding)
Okay, first thing we do
is announce the zip code of the day.
And in honor of you it's...
64112 Kansas city, Missouri. My hometown.
(audience applauding)
I was so excited to celebrate Kansas city
with you as we did it the news desk last time.
And it's also the home of our affiliate station.
KSHB TV channel 41.
Hi guys.
So Heidi, what are some fun facts about Kansas city?
Okay. Well, Kansas city has over 200 working fountains
giving it the nickname of The City of Fountains.
That's pretty cool.
The Country Club Plaza opened in 1922.
It's the US first suburban shopping district.
And every thanksgiving the Plaza lights ceremony happens
where a hometown hero flips the switch
to turn on the Christmas lights.
And I was so honored to have done it in 2019.
(audience applauding)
That must feel really good.
Like, you know, it sometimes in life
something tells you you're on the right track.
Yes. It felt amazing.
It was like just a sea of Kansas Citians
out there supporting me to turn on lights.
So it was really cool.
Okay. Kansas city, Missouri
would you please put pen to paper?
We would love to hear from you.
Please write us.
I don't know how to describe it
but there is something life affirming about mail.
Yes. And it's how it used to be.
Like, you get a letter in the mail you feel special.
I mean, look at this envelope.
If that doesn't bring you joy, then you're dead inside.
(audience laughing)
All right, let's open our first letter.
Okay. I am going to open it right here.
Dear drew,
I lost two jobs at the start of the pandemic.
So I've had to fall back on my art
as my only means of income and therapy.
Making my creations.
I called them Rightmojis has really saved my life.
The goal with my art is to bring a smile to people's faces.
And I know you share the same sentiment with your show.
Thank you.
That is the goal, rightmoji.
So as a thank you
and hopefully to bring a smile to your face
I created this Drew's news magnet as a gift for you.
Okay. This is the cutest thing ever.
This is so sweet
and it does bring a huge smile to--
Oh, there are multiples.
Look at those.
Oh, they're beautiful.
(audience applauding)
By the way, good blush.
You look great.
Well, rightmoji,
I love these.
And I'm going to send you $2,500
that you can put towards just continuing your passion
and doing what you do.
And just to say thank you.
And we recognize your work
and admire it very much, Heidi, your turn.
Drew I love what you were doing so much.
So should we send another $2,500?
(audience applauding)
Yes...
Please, please thank you Heidi.
Thank you for letting me share the love.
That's exactly right.
All right Heidi, you have a letter
sent from one of your pen pals, actually.
I'd love for you to share.
Okay.
Dear Heidi,
Thank you so much for thinking of us and sending a card.
We have a therapy dog named Prada who visits every Saturday.
We miss seing her and can't wait
until she can come back to see us.
We are also looking into therapy cats to visit.
Your cat just had a birthday.
Did your cat enjoy his tuna birthday cake?
We hope he enjoyed it.
From your friends at Seneca place.
Verona, Pennsylvania.
Oh, Heidi that's so sweet.
No, I know.
I love that.
All right, we have time for one more.
Hi Drew,
I'm writing for some advice.
Ooh...
I'm 20 years old and have never been on a first date.
It seems to me that you have been on well over 51st dates.
So I need your help.
Give me everything you've got.
Sincerely Angie.
All right.
Here's what I'm going to say.
And it actually is directly related to 51st dates.
The thing I fell in love with that story was to me
it was a great allegory
about someone who finds the energy to be kind
to someone every day.
And I think that that is the epitome of a good relationship.
If you can find it in your heart to muster up kindness
and patience and a sense of humor
and maybe even a sense of adventure on a regular basis
that's what 51st dates is about.
And when you go on your first date
maybe have that as an intention
of someone you're looking for
is going to be good to you on a daily basis.
I love that.
Really?
(laughing)
She's beautiful advice for anyone for a married woman.
It's beautiful.
All right, Heidi, do you have any advice for Angie?
You know what? I do have some advice for Angie.
You're 20 years old Angie,
I bet you're a wonderful young woman
and I just want to encourage you to be that young woman
on your date.
Just have fun and be you and it's going to be great.
Yeah.
I love that advice.
It's so true.
Well, if you need any help or advice
or maybe want to see something or try something new,
Then mail questions request photos and heartfelt
or funny stories to find out more and get our address.
Go to
Well, should we say it together?
Truly yours Drew and Heidi.
(upbeat music)